as always the episode is brought to you
by a gray block pizza 18:11 Pico
Boulevard on the way to the beach you
know are you Italian you can be get that
hitter so you should know that we're all
so inundated with emails now that it's
no longer about responding to everything
you know you only respond to things you
need to respond to but the problem is
you got so much done they got so much
dirty clutter out their email clutter
but that can change now because they
have a thing called sandbox SI NE bo X
and it does the work for you it goes
through and gets all the dirt out a tear
okay and it keeps the messages you need
to respond to sandbox also has a special
feature called the same black hole where
you can drag messages from annoying
senders that you never want to hear from
again ever again oh I want that so bad
we could just drag them over there boom
yous out of my life because your inbox
is your life now it's like your heart in
your brain made one little beautiful
place to get mail but you can use
sandbox now to magically remove
distractions from your inbox with a free
two week trial that's right just for our
listeners here we got that free two week
trial for this past weekend listeners
visit sandbox comm slash Theo today to
start your free trial and receive a $25
credit that's that $25 credit si any BOE
x.com slash th e oh oh
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
mmm-hmm what's up you little roasted
cranberries what you guys doing uh who's
out there what's going on what's going
on
dang man I've been having nah you know I
get seasonal jock itch and this isn't an
advertisement I actually get seasonal
jock itch and and I noticed man this is
gonna say I'm me I don't sometimes for
me I'm not saying this everybody but for
me sometimes my you know most rodham you
know minuttes are nuts as a soft you my
nuts
will the it's like the inside of them
will itch and it's an impossible it's an
impossible you can't get in there you
know yeah you can I mean you can the the
best you can do as a human is it's the
outside of your nuts you know and I
think it is that and I'm not trying to
be based here I'm not trying to be you
know base or you know vile I'm not
trying to be a bad you know you know a
bad little Daniel you know who's been
out in the you know smoking dope in the
yard and hide and you know hide and he
you know hiding sugar treats you know
different sugar treats in the chimney
and stuff like that and trying to keep
you know sugar treats from his brothers
and sisters I'm not trying to be like a
bad Daniel you know I'm just telling you
that I'm just telling you that that
sometimes you have so you have an itch
on the inside and you came to you and
you can't reach it man sometimes there's
things you can't reach you know there's
parts you you can't just change and
adjust with your hands you're knocking
yeah I could look I could I could
scratch anything it's on the outside of
my you know my nuts are my squat you
know scratching and I can do it you can
do any of that but sometimes if there's
the tin society you you got to go a
little further you know you have to go a
little deeper and you have to actually
do work you got to do work you know you
got a you have to make it you have to
take the long way through your brain and
through your neck and through your belly
and through you know you got to go the
long way to quell that inner inch you
know I can't each the inside of my nuts
I can only each the outside but
sometimes after scratching on the
outside of my nuts for so long it's just
you know it's it's just I'm not really
really solving with that that inner you
know that inner chiki chiki chiki that's
in my squat tune and so that's where I'm
at right now is uh you know I'm wanting
to do that hard work I wanted to put in
that dirty w you know that dirty work to
get I want the inside of my nuts looking
clean y-you know when I go up to heaven
you know when I go up you know to North
Haven bruh
cuz I'm not hanging out in South heaven
you know a lot of people would be like
i'ma go to heaven you know you're gonna
get into heaven but what part you're
gonna live in you know you're gonna be
in South heaven [ __ ] that okay a knock
knock who's there a [ __ ] dad [ __ ] that
is here I wanna live in North heaven
okay I don't want to be over there in
South have more people you know poppin
off and you know they got you know
pigeons out there you know pigeons out
there selling drugs on they wings and
[ __ ] I don't want that I want to live up
there in North heaven you know where the
inside of me is is just as as pristine
as the outside and so that's why I'm mad
sometimes today I've been thinking about
man I'm you know I'm trying to scratch
some of these in or itches and I can't
it's just they're not things I can do
with my hands there are things I got to
go I got to work harder you know I got
to take extra action I got a you know I
just have to put in the work I have to
do the work do the work welcome to this
past weekend I appreciate you guys being
here with with with each other
you know and sometimes I think about
like who is listening and I think like
who's listening
you know who's listening you know I
think about maybe it's like a um
somebody that's selling kites you know a
little kite salesman a little lady
you know just drop you know maybe she
got a little buggy or a little cart and
she pushing that cart around you know
just slinging them fake birds baby them
kites and air kites you know I think
about a lady is just you know kind of
she you know she got a couple you know
like a little kite buggy and she should
just put you know you know pedaling them
kites because people forget about kites
dude before they had birds they had
kites you know and people you know and I
don't know I don't even know if that's
true but I don't know what the timeline
of it all is but before they had you
know it's sometime birds weren't they
weren't doing what they were supposed to
do and so kites and so somebody made
kites you know a scientist or you know
engineer which is basically an engineer
as a scientist had actually [ __ ] does
something okay you know let's known for
everybody must talk about scientists and
this and that
in lab coats and people bringing their
own lunch to the you know to the lab you
know and doing all that you know when
somebody grilling up a lull you know
what can of um anchovies on some on a
book on a Bunsen burner [ __ ] all of that
man the scientists but who's really
doing [ __ ] is engineers ok engineers are
basically people that are they come in
to they come in and they see what a
scientist is doing and then they
actually take it and do some [ __ ] ok cuz
scientists will just mill around in a
laboratory their whole life mixing
things you know making one dude was in
there for a month he made kool-aid like
bruh that ain't [ __ ] duck you know
saying at least come out with some you
know something wild some [ __ ] guava
menthol you know magic hitter sauce but
engineers actually do something
okay engineers actually do something and
so that's what I think about who's out
there listening to this you know who's
listening to this to this podcast you
know maybe an engineer you know maybe
somebody that's armed who could be
listening
oh maybe somebody that's on a dance team
like a lady that's not like an adult
dance team you know when she's you know
she's stuck in traffic and she got
sequins and all on her and some of this
she's sweating and so some of the
sequins is getting all wet and she's
listening to this past weekend or maybe
a milkman you know they got a lot of
milk man's out there and if you don't
know what a milkman a milkman is um oh
it was always talking about kites bro
I just remember yeah I think somebody
that could be listening is a kite maker
you know because there was a time in
history this where I went there was a
time in history when Birds gave up on
themselves you know a lot of different
things happen bird flew up some bird
knew a bird and a pig you know did
something and swine flu hit the air so
they had bird flu and swine flu in the
air at the same time [ __ ] you know
turkey sausage really the market went
downhill that T s market and there were
no birds in the air for I don't know how
long could have been six or seven years
and that's when kites were invented
because people still wanted to see
things in the sky you know I'm saying if
you look at the sky there's nothing in
it you get [ __ ] bored as [ __ ] but now
that somebody made kites and a kite is
just a paper bird on a string you know
it's just that one-dimensional [ __ ]
bird you know a kite you get a kite up
in air and a kite you know you get that
kite up there and you know especially if
somebody's dumb or if they're a kid they
think it's a bird you know from 40 feet
away a kite is a [ __ ] bird you know
that might not want you know maybe a
long you know tampon string in or
something you know I don't know what a
kid thinks but but they had you know a
picture maybe somebody like that because
they had that time when birds took a
break in kites
and kites took over for birds and people
don't give kites as much credit but I
figure something up maybe somebody
that's listening to this podcast as a
kite is a kite person somebody sells
kites or somebody who makes some
somebody who sells milk you know
somebody up there slinging that [ __ ]
cow drip drip you know that moo moo
freaking you know that moo moo SH you
know that moo moo shake maker milk you
know that could be somebody I think of a
man driving around in his milk truck you
know he's probably got a little bit of
milk coming off his mouth and I bet he
keeps it there you know I bet every now
and then he takes a little sip and let
some dribble out just in case the ladies
see him and they want to know what he's
about and suddenly they look at his lips
and they say damn this boys about that
leak leak you know this boys about that
drip [ __ ] and then they see that that's
the kind of man they want all kind of
man it's gonna make these you know these
bad bye bye see Gus did it deep and so
that maybe that's somebody that's out
there you know some badass [ __ ] milk
boy riding in that leche truck you know
you see me rollin we yogurt trying to
catch me milk and bruh trying to kill
catch me milk and drippy so who we all
smell that's who I think who listens to
this you know maybe an adult lady that's
kind of sweaty on a dance team or you
know somebody's daddy maybe some 50 year
old man or 70 year old man he might be
listening to this [ __ ] but whoever is
listening I want you to know that uh
that thank you thank you for listening
and thanks for being here with me what
was uh what was something I was just
looking at it was um on Twitter Oh Nick
Saban apologized for you know he was
talking with a female reporter or a
reporter okay he was talking with a
reporter after a or at a halftime of a
football game or after the game and she
was asking him all these questions and
she asked him about the quarterback kind
of controversy and they just won the
game really handling and you can use two
quarterbacks if you want you could use
four quarterback
in the game if you want to and his
response was this well I still think
well I still like both guys Sabin said I
think both guys can help our team
alright so why do you continually try to
get me to say something that doesn't
respect one of them I'm not going to so
quit asking and I thought that was the
greatest statement that I've heard you
know it's it's interesting when guys uh
it's like why can't we be honest in the
face of the media like why do you why
why these people continually fear a lot
of times like the media has the power
this is one of the most powerful
statements I've heard like just because
you can come considerably ask some
continually ask somebody something and
you're just trying to start [ __ ] you
know there's two young men that are in
college okay and yeah they're playing in
athletics in college and they're at you
know Alabama which is a great College
I'm not saying that but you know there
are football players out so probably
their primary focus is football and that
you know a secondary or segundo focus is
is uh is at academics but these are
still two men young men whose lives are
you know their lives and futures so this
reporter by asking that kind of stuff
you're just gonna get these guys to like
say stuff and and cause he'll so I just
don't understand I guess like what is it
what does the media get out of that like
what if you keep asking about these two
got like that's just putting stress on
them save and solve the issue he has two
quarterbacks played the game and they
won by 50 points or something it should
be at that point that it solved and
that's where I'm saying man this media
it's just [ __ ] you know yeah you
don't what do you get out of that that's
just hateful because now you have this
man you're putting him back on the spot
even though he already not only did he
tell you it's up to him and not only did
he already let you he let you guys know
in advance you know news media before
the game that he's put in two
quarterbacks in
like he's offering up all the
information he can and you're not happy
so it's what so it's not about getting
information anymore then it's just about
stirring up [ __ ] and I'm just so happy
that Nick Saban said it he apologized
for it after but screw that I wish he
wouldn't have because at a certain point
the media yet the media you have a right
to ask questions but you also have a
right if somebody wants to call you an
[ __ ] or somebody wants to call you
greedy cuz you know you're just like
what do you hope to get out of that if I
know somebody already did something
they've solved the problem at that point
it's just about me it's not about them
anymore I don't really want to know what
Nick said I don't really want there's no
controversy like I respect Nick Saban
for saying this and I and I loved his
word choice why do you continually try
to get me to say something that doesn't
respect one of them because in turn not
what he's saying but what is also being
implied is that these news had outlets
they don't respect these guys so why try
to act concerned about the players you
know if you don't respect them I I found
were them I would love how never let
those people ask questions again but
then here's where it gets tricky is the
the football the the teams have deals
with the networks and the advertisers
and so that's how the advertise so they
have to answer questions of the certain
network so if that's a network reporter
I'm not sure my have been an ESPN
reporter but if it's an ESPN reporter
they have to answer that question and
I'm not sure I'm not sure where what
reporter it was I saw it but I didn't
see you know the insignia on the little
microphone or whatever but but sometimes
there's deals in there so that's why he
even has to do that and I bet somebody
probably called him and said well look
you know that these advertisers pay the
network that's how we make all our money
so we need you to apologize I don't know
if that's true I could be totally [ __ ]
wrong but I can say it if I want to you
know I can imply some things that I'm
thinking and that's what I just did
so I didn't get heat on that but also I
did mean to [ __ ] that man make me mad
you know when I don't like getting mad
cuz when I get mad you know I feel like
somebody turns on a little stove and
that's in the inside of me I like a
senior citizen here's what I feel like
like a senior citizen turns on the stove
on me ins on the inside and forgets
about the stove and this turns me on
even just just light heat basic heat you
know Heat number one or two and they
just forget about it so that's how and
then I just simmer I got this simmer
going on boy and all I want to do is
make tea that's all I want to do with my
anger is make tea with it and make it
mmm just a wildly [ __ ] violent
detroit chamomile but instead it's just
the light just the just the gas is just
burning and that's how I feel sometimes
when I get a little bit of anger it's
exactly how I feel from now on I wanna
let you know when I give you my dates
it's gonna be so fast man it's gonna be
like 15 seconds coming up next week I'll
be in Nashville and then I am in Toronto
for three nights other cities Charlotte
Appleton Phoenix Buffalo Salt Lake City
and Washington DC Theo von comm slash
tour see how I did that oh man what else
what was that thing about hmm he had
this weekend what did I do I didn't do
much you know what happened was I
started you know I last week I was
pretty depressed you know honestly I was
pretty depressed and sometimes my
depression just hits me and it's tough
and if my depression kind of hits me at
the same time where I'm not like
managing my life super well then it can
really you know create kind of crevasse
you know and I fall down and in that
crevasse like a dirty you know like a um
you know like a little Plinko chip but
Plinko chip and then at the bottom
instead of winning money you just got
you know seitan right there with his
mouth open and I fall right on into the
devil's throat and then I get
lackadaisical and it all builds on
itself blah blah blah
you know and that's just kind of like
yeah I just got depressed this past week
and it carried over into the weekend and
then yesterday things started getting
better because I started just moving my
feet you know I started moving my feet I
started moving my feet and that was it
sometimes I don't think you know
something I'll think super well and so
when I don't went out when my brain
isn't helping me I have to use my feet
feet-first you know and my brain will
follow if you move your feet your
thoughts will follow that is it if
you're just sitting there thinking about
moving your feet they may never move but
if you move those mo feets you move
those motor feeders then your brains
gonna follow right behind them that's
how it works for me we had some good
calls that came in I want to let you
know you can hit the hotline here nine
eight five six six four nine five zero
three you can always hit the hotline if
you're struggling if you are not
struggling you have a comment on
something we're talking about you want
to you know be a part of the show you
want to anything be a part of the show
nine eight five six six four nine five
zero three that's toll-free and that's
it you know you can hit that hotline and
the intro music today was by Jameson
flood and that man was named after damn
just intense water can you imagine can
you imagine when his mother's water
broke at Birth him must have been a
naughty naughty just just drams and
drams of just that you know that
humanity h2o just flying out of mama if
they named him flood and that's Jameson
flood and that's not me that's a nun
clickable link there's not even a link
you can go to get that to get that
[ __ ] you know that magic that sound
magic so this is a that's just something
he emailed me and he's called it a smoky
little beat so if you if your eyes start
itch and that's it because that's a
smoky little beat by Jameson flood let's
let's take somebody's called Matt this
calls we're flowing right in and here we
go this was a caller about last week's
music a p.m. Mike from West Virginia
Mike from West Virginia
in West Virginia man it's the kind of
place where you know you might be you
know you might go over to a girl's place
start hooking up with her and next thing
you know you know y'all live in us you
know what I'm saying it's your house
actually you at you know that's where a
sibling live you know that's sibling
rivalry sometimes the rivalry is [ __ ]
you know and there's nothing wrong with
that I mean there's no there's something
wrong with you you shouldn't be here's
what my here's what I you know here's
what was always said around me when I
was growing up if you if you rearrange
the letters of sister it spells resist
and that's the truth boy so that's the
rule right there you know if you guys if
both you all have the same parents then
you know I'm saying you guys know
candles at dinner you know what I'm
saying keep it classy but you know
legally it's it's legally okay to to
marry and engage sensually with a first
cousin I believe that's the truth
because and a lot of this is just a long
time ago do back in the day man see if
you got an erection first of all you
know this that the first time people got
erections they thought it was you know
their penis was trying to tell him where
something was you know it was like your
paint it was just a little like I like
having like a little meet Lassie you
know you know how when lassie kind of
tells you what's going on that's what a
paint a penis was like because suddenly
you're walking around and you get that
hitter you get that sheboygan you know
you get that womb and he's skansen you
know you get that you know that direct
wiener and some people do when you think
about an erection think about this a lot
of you ladies out there you don't know
that when you first get an erection you
don't know what it is okay and I
remember thinking
something was trying to get out of my
body and I even remember this man oh
this is almost embarrassing to say but I
thought it was because you know if you
have poops in your body and this is a
little grotesque and I don't mean for it
to be but I'm not I'm not not gonna
share things I've thought about because
they might be a little grotesque at
times if you've had ever poops and you
know and everybody has poops in their
body but when you're young you're still
learning about all of that in your body
you know you still you know you don't
know what's going on and one of your
nipples is real hard and you know when
you got an ear infection and you got
tubes and years and you got braces and
you know one of your legs clicks when
you want you know you're still learning
everything's still kind of happened but
I remember when I first got any erection
I thought it was like a poop was trying
to get out of my body and they'd gone
the wrong way and I remember thinking
like oh my god dude
like a bunch of or not a bunch but at
least one kind of decently long poop has
you know got caught up in a some type of
deal when it's headed the wrong
direction and that's what I thought it
was from being like oh my god how do you
know how do I get this poop to turn
around inside of my body and I remember
actually praying about it I'm were
praying and praying and then it and it
went away and it went away just
naturally is an erection
you know because erection they don't you
know they hang out for a little bit and
then they they go you know it's
basically like the Punxsutawney Phil of
your pants you know they show up maybe
they see a shadow maybe they you know
looking for a little lady or something
and they go on and that's what happened
I was like oh my God thank God it turned
around you know and then late at a
different point I asked my brother about
and he told me that's an erection but
people out but I remember hearing all
kinds of stories from my friends about
what they thought erections were you
know when people had all different ideas
about um about erections and what they
could be
and maybe we'll do an episode about that
like just like you know the different
things that you thought an erection was
you know because a lot of women don't
realize that when you get there's no
real reason for part of your body to
suddenly turn hard you know unless a
wizard put a spell on you you know you
know immediate us rigor mortis
you know you there's no real reason for
it anyhow let's go on man let's hear a
little bit more thank you for calling
there Mike from West Virginia just
wanted to share something I just started
the podcast that you put out and you
play that that tiny thing whoo oh yeah
that tiny sand who cuppa Oh Paradise
City man dude that took way back to 1988
through when I was five years old with
my aunt
Miami school [ __ ] man hell yeah dude
well first of all your aunt must have
been cool she letting you listened to
Guns and Roses at five years old man
that's really really classy but I loved
that actually that's beautiful to think
about onward my cousin was three years
older me and he had that CD he was like
eight years older he had that CD Guns
and Roses Appetite for Destruction dude
as anytime I would go to every was a
damn that [ __ ] all kinds of man that
took me back and I just wanted to once I
thank you and Ty nice and here at work
that was cool [ __ ] man all right brother
I'll be listening have a good day you
have a good day too man you know what's
in you I don't know where you I well I
know where your friend from West
Virginia but that's just a you know
that's a state but you know I can tell
just by the sound of your voice wherever
you are that's where I'm from right
where you were I Briggs whatever you're
saying that is I can just I'm from that
place I'm from where somebody in my
neighborhood have had that appetite for
destruction dude and we put that on and
we lost our minds brother we lost our
minds dude I remember this people loved
that music so much one dude this dude
named Eddie he had this drop top you
know it was a convertible
exhale even if it was a convertible I
think someone honestly
maybe somebody might have stole the top
of his car because they had a summer in
our in our neighborhood where somebody
stole the top of everybody's car and and
they ended up bust and the person they
were trying to make a boat and so I
guess they thought if they got enough
car tops it would kind of make a boat
you know and I could see that I could
see how that would work so but anyhow
you know and Eddie was the smoothest
dudebro you know he was about five feet
tall but he had about seven feet of hair
bra I mean just a dam just a [ __ ]
just like a falcon that flew right out
of the [ __ ] it just of the dang Lord
you know we just landed right in our
damn neighborhood and I mean he used to
let us touch his hair and and it wasn't
sexual or nothing he was just it was
just like he just brought up you know it
was like he'd just been out you know
riding a couple horses and he just
brought him in to drink water and he let
us stand there and touch him while it
was drinking water and that was us just
touching them you know he had beautiful
air anyhow so he had a he had a Ford
Mustang convertible or just a foot or
just some kind of car he basically had
some kind of car and he had Appetite for
Destruction dude Paradise City and he
put that thing in and and this might
have been even when it was tapes its
mind of me man I haven't CDs and he had
a couple local yeah you know he found a
couple of local bad birds over there and
they lived over near though they said it
was a river but it really it was a kind
of a sewage outlet kind of a Creek slash
kind of drainage they call it drainage
and and he had a he finally had a couple
ladies that lived over there near the
drainage and he had them standing in the
car standing up on the backseat and he
would drive up and down the street and
play that
and these chicks would just dance and
dance and one time he he gassed it a
little hard and one of them yet just
fell right off the back dude right on
that another [ __ ] Street brah and we
still [ __ ] sang and party dude we
didn't care cuz that song was beautiful
dude but they had a family the Wilsons
that lived about two blocks from me
growing up and I remember when I was
yelling the Wilsons they their family
was wild and the mother had passed away
you know the mother Wilson I don't
remember what happened to her man she
had died you know and they had they had
her ashes on the mantle but this family
went a lot of Guns & Roses in
rock-and-roll music would come on they
blindfold the whole family would get
blindfolded right her tie something
around their head and just mosh pit in
the living room the daddy and three boys
okay and they would just be [ __ ] mosh
pit and Brun losing their minds dude and
that's how they showed affection to one
another you know it's really beautiful
to think about it different ways you
know different you know there's a
there's a some type of animal I think
it's a mom marmoset or something but if
they get upset if they love another
animal they rip its head off that's how
they show it love dude that's crazy
flamingos and if you know this or not if
they love another flamingos they like
[ __ ] buy it
that's you know that's that's that ain't
no Valentine's Day as far as I'm
concerned but two flamingos that's their
universe you know different people have
different ways of showing affections but
the Wilson family they would get and
they have one son this boy named yikes
yikes was his name you know kind of like
you know like he Ike's like uh like
you're scared but still trying to seem
kind of cool and he but the family I
remember their [ __ ] rage in one night
everybody's got you know blindfold and
one of them had on like a sleeping mask
that like a senior citizen beware like a
like a supermodel kind of wears when
they sleep and and the dad he had of a
just a shirt kind of tied around his
eyes you know real tight and they were
just losing their minds just listening
to Guns and Roses in the living room and
somebody swung their arm and and I think
it was yikes and not the mother's urn
the urn of ashes into the air and they
don't [ __ ] know it but I know it I'm
watching and I saw these four boys do
just dance in a Paradise City just in
their mother's ashes bruh as the ashes
just fill in the room you know just you
know and they're just losing their
[ __ ] minds mosh pit and and it was
beautiful you know it's just beautiful
to see that family together you know
even in that kind of this cryptic sort
of wild kind of you know bad dancing
sort of sense and then one of the kids
one time they were doing that stuff
blindfolded and dancing and having fun
together and showing love and uh one of
them blindfolded themselves with a
plastic bag over their whole head and
ended up in a coma I think her son so
yeah and he might have died I don't
think he died but you know he did not
die so we'll just leave it right there
but I remember those times man and I
love that I love when music takes you
back to a place you know when sometimes
I wonder if our brains can remember
everything that we've ever done we just
need to be we need a clue like we need a
reminder like sometimes I'll walk in
somebody's house and I'll smell and I'll
be like oh this smells like so-and-so's
house you know where they used to you
know they used to raise snakes you know
and you know and and it'll take me back
there you know or oh this reminds me of
uh you know the gravel here reminds me
of of the gravel of you know this
hunting camp that we used to go to or
this fishing camp we used to go to and
suddenly I'm back there with all the
memories it's like sometimes I just I
wonder if our brains can hold it all we
just have to have at we have to have a
clue you know or a moment helped us
access last week's episode we talked a
little bit about uh you know commitment
if feelings like that and so I just want
to you guys had some calls in response
to some of the stuff that I was feeling
so I wanted to hear some of you guys
have thoughts here we go yeah Nicholas
from Canada manager Colin hey Nicholas
in Toronto and I'll be coming up there
September 20th through the 22nd or
something like that but the tickets are
all available right now I am doing three
nights in Toronto home work that group
think episode and kind of validate your
feelings man because a lot of stuff
you're saying that you think you had
about relationships and not being able
to commit properly in a healthy way just
all that kind of stuff you're just doing
a lot of stuff that I've literally
thought to myself four-day them and cool
man I'm glad that uh yeah I mean I'm
glad we can have some of the same you
know thoughts and ideas on word think a
lot of it has to do with just like a lot
of childhood stuff they say all your
life ships are based off high release
typically parents let's go have a great
one man I love you and appreciate
everything you do for us everyone thanks
for calling in man I appreciate that as
you said a lot of the things the
relationships we have the way we behave
in them are based on the relationship we
had as a as a child you know so yeah so
oh sorry so I guess that's my brother
right there
hey bud now I must man I'm on the
podcast right now how are you how's the
beach going nice the kids look like they
were having fun I saw that picture of
them in the sand that's awesome good for
you man it's hard to uh
I bet it's hard to probably because it's
a time for you to rest but it does
probably know sometimes are just no rest
[Music]
good for you dude yeah that's true if I
guess if you're percent yeah if you go
in thinking this is a vacation and but
it's a family trip you're gonna be
you're just gonna be disappointed yeah
awesome man well uh let me I'm gonna
finish up this podcast I'll call you
when I get done man all right love you
too but
brother right there so I'll probably
just keep that in my brother's at the
beach dude you know he got to take his
kids down there and yes funny I was
looking at I love my brother so much man
I love him so much you know
sorry to say got me sentimental
I love hearing my brother's voice you
know were we what we were just okay well
let's talk about what we're disarming
with the call you know the the
relationships you had as a child will
that will be determined how you
relationships you have as an adult and
some guessing the ones that your parents
men and women and so this goes right in
actually even my brother does Colin you
know my father and I did not have a
relationship the more I think about it
I've tried a search inside of myself to
find what our relationship was we had
some moments that we shared but we did
not have a real relationship at all so
fast-forward that now you know one of
the things even just here my brother
getting to talk to him right you know
getting to talk to my brother and he's
at the beach with his kids on you know
they're in Florida or somewhere you know
Florida dude [ __ ] the closest I got
to Florida as a kid was just seen it on
a t-shirt just singing somebody had a
shirt that said [ __ ] Florida on it so
to see him now like there with his kids
and like you know and not only thinking
about you know just thinking about you
know telling me what the difference
between a vacation and a family trip is
you know it's just I mean it all just
blows my mind because I don't have a
relationship with my dad so then the
relation of my with my brother you know
or with men growing like I've never
really had a really good relationship
with a lot of men you know I think I've
always wanted more one but I never
really have known how to put together
some of the pieces so you know even in
the last few years having better
friendships and better guys that I can
call and talk to I mean I had friends
growing up but
I never always felt like the consumption
with the connection so now you know I
really is really it's awesome to me to
have connection with with other men and
to be able to connect to them you know
and to be able to not just you know I
can bro out and joke around forever
I'll joke around all day dude you know I
joke around - my lips fall off bro and
you know we end up in somebody's damn
boots or something but but not you know
but it but justice to actually have a
real connection that's you know that's
that's nice and so so anyway that's just
a nice moment to get to think about my
brother and his family at the beach
brings me a lot of joy and just to know
that his kids are down there having fun
you know with their dad and we grew up
in the same environment and it just
wasn't a lot of love in the house there
was a lot of there was a lot of good
stuff but there was not a lot of love
and there was not a lot of connection so
for him to care about those things that
just means a lot to me you know it makes
me feel it makes me feel it makes me
feel hopeful that that kind of stuff is
in my inside of me too
you know when I see my brother able to
do those things I think the truth is it
gives me hope that those things are
inside of me as well you know the
ability to have that commitment and
connection and to make that a real thing
you know it's some people might be like
we'll deal quit whining about this kind
of [ __ ] you know you talk about all
these thing you must said too much well
that's fine brah
but I want to think about this kind of
stuff you know I want to think about
you know I don't want to feel about Who
I am you know uh I like it uh uh you
know I like trying to learn more about
why I behave a certain way and you know
I want to I want to be happy so I'm
gonna I don't know I don't know what I'm
doing all the time but but I'm gonna
keep my feet moving that's what I'm
gonna do you know this week got the best
of me at some points but not today
[ __ ] I'm keeping my feet moving
but yeah I think but it's true some of
the relationships we had growing up and
it's true out how I treat women it's
hard for me to connect I feel
uncomfortable and you know and it's just
it's tough it's tough for me to think of
a long-term connection probably because
when I was young and my connection with
my mother I didn't think that it was
long-term it never felt like it was
gonna be long-term and it wasn't you
know I was emancipated at 14 before that
I was sleeping on friends you know for a
year and a half I was sleeping over at
friends houses and uh and that was it
you know and that was a lot of it and we
have a relationship now but you know at
that point in my life that's what a
relationship with a woman was and it had
been disjointed since I was a child you
know I never you know I remember asking
my mother a few years ago I tried this
Landmark Forum thing and it's where you
going it's like a seminar thing and
different things work for different
people so I don't shot any of that stuff
you know unless they out there shave and
sheep and you know looking in you
[ __ ] with a flashlight or something
some of that [ __ ] could be shady you
know if you uh put air sheep over there
sheep shavers Union over there nah in
South Carolina that [ __ ] you don't even
shoot it down shut it down but this
seemed you know like more normal and and
I remember at one of the breaks they're
like you know go talk to somebody in
your life and ask them a question you've
always want to ask them and armory just
came into my head I went to ask my mom
if she loved me when I was a kid
that's I called her and asked her man
and I was blubbering I was blubbering in
tears I was like an idiot and I just
asked her if she loved me when I was a
child because I didn't I didn't I didn't
him up
it's not that I didn't know my feelings
didn't know you know there's a
difference between you telling me
something or me thinking something and
me feeling it and and I asked her I said
you know did you did you love me when I
was a kid and she said yes she did you
know but I'd never felt it and so I
needed that I needed to at least hear
her say it anyhow I've been rambling off
on that let's get to a few more
questions here man or a few this is
these are more comments from last week
we're talking about commitment here's a
couple more thoughts that came in and
we'll get to some a couple of questions
homeward hey what's up uncle Vaughn this
relaxers calling you from El Paso Texas
what's up Alexis from El Paso and uh
uncle Vaughn it is all more brother me
amigo triplet town I was just into the
podcast man just right now I finished it
oh thank you for listening Alexis I
appreciate you brother and El Paso is
the only city in America while I was on
the interstate once and I saw a human
fee see travel right across somebody
thrown it over the interstate and they
got people under two interstates over
there just humming turds out there just
straight-up
lobbing T's up in there and just just
you know just just lobbing
turrets over across interstate and I've
never seen a human feces fly like that
across the interstate and um you know
and I guess I'm like [ __ ] dude they
don't have Birds or kites around here
they just make and am just body kites
you know and just just lob in turrets
out here onward and you're talking about
that marriage you know talking about
that being together with somebody and
just you know my commitment and uh I
think I think I know a little bit about
commitment man I've been [ __ ] been
married for nine years eight years eight
nine years or eight years bruh
dude you know you're committed when
you've already said nine that's a
Freudian
right there you know when it's only
eight and you said nine that is
commitment man mas mas he's gonna have
something like that so I should know
that but I was three and 17 when I got
married and uh Wow seventeen when you
got married that is that's a quinceanera
that's birthday say sanera
and then the COTC nee arab boy damn boy
the COTC era was for a Viera Owen that's
[ __ ] it's worked out for me man if I
didn't have a wonderful life you know my
wife my kids I just had a little
daughter and all congratulations man
that's awesome you know I love hearing
you say you had a one you have a
wonderful life you know cuz it's about
that it's about your perspective of it
you know and you can hear it in your
voice you sound happy man you sound he
sounds so happy dude homework [ __ ]
badass man I love it and my thing is
just take it take it to prison think you
know you gotta [ __ ] just go straight
out and let her know where you're
[ __ ] thinking you know where you're
at what you want where you you know I
just told the first thing I thought my
wife was [ __ ] you know I [ __ ] love
you and I want to [ __ ] be with you I
don't know that I'm a little high look
enjoy but eh it's been working man and
uh [ __ ] love your [ __ ] keep on doing
what you're doing man gracias man even
meant a bro even meant a Mia more
hermano that's great man um I love my
wife I'm [ __ ] high that's great good
for you man look you sound happy dude
you sound happy to me and I applaud you
brother
and.and you sound like you love your
family and those are the you know that's
the most important thing you know you're
happy and you love your family do what
greater gifts could we have in the world
you know your kids are growing up
feeling loved by their father dang boy
that's deep that's the deepest waters
brah you know that's the most beautiful
that's the most beautiful turd and El
Paso right there bruh you know and I
don't mean that in a derogatory sense
saying us that love boy just that air
just that body just that body uh time
capsule bro dude a turd is just a time
capsule that's all it is man that's all
it is a turd is just a time capsule
let's hear another call thank you for
calling brother homeward yeah what's up
this is Riley from Phoenix Arizona
what's up Riley from Phoenix I'll be in
Phoenix October 28th housing in Phoenix
October 27th with Brendan Schaub and
Harry Shaffir and Brian Collins
onward Colin was listening to your
thoughts on commitment and how you
struggle with that as well this is
definitely something I struggle with and
just thinking on it it's like you're
playing with like house money if you
don't fully give yourself if you don't
fully commit your you're all right as
bad things happen and that has kind of
always followed me hmm that's
interesting appointment yeah if you
don't fully commit then you're okay
because if bad things happen you weren't
all the way in anyway if you ain't
swimming around in the water and you
just sitting on the pool with your legs
in there you know and your thoughts and
some of your feeling you throw in some
of your feelings out into the water but
you're still sitting on the side or
you're holding onto the side of the pool
and if the water goes out of the pool
[ __ ] fall then you weren't all the way
in anyway so if that pool is the
relationship and the water goes out you
you weren't a fully invested any way you
still holding on to the side you still
sitting over there you know maybe having
a couple of her.she her.she cups or
whatever peanut butter
you know snack cups but if you're out
there swimming then you're taking those
chances with your emotions you putting
your [ __ ] emotions out there in that
and then a chlorine so yes uh yeah
here's the crazy thing for me though I
can't tell if I'm all the way in
you know I can't feel if I'm I think I'm
all the way in sometimes I think there's
so many there's just some fears inside
of me that are like like so like just
like barnacles inside of me that that
are did that grip on the edge of the
pool no matter what and that's why I'm
at now I'm in there trying to work away
I'm trying to get that scratch out of
the inside of me you know trying to get
get in and do that work on the inside of
me so that I ain't out here just
scratching my nuts all the time and I'm
you know I'm digging that itch out from
the end from the inside all more brother
and this relationship getting out here
you know like I only put in 75 if
something bad happens I was never really
fully in to get hurt but you know just
out here taken Bobby got the wheel
tournament there to think about stuff
some congress's dope I appreciate it I
appreciate you dude I proceed you : I
appreciate you thinking and I appreciate
you sharing that thought if you don't go
all the way in then of course you know
how you expect it to work
something to work if you ain't all the
way into it anyway by out there no
matter I'm not talking to anybody I'm
talking to myself
you know how do I expect uh how do I
expect to really feel loved by somebody
and to feel the to really feel the love
and the joy of a relationship of a
connection
if I'm not doing my part you know if I'm
not wholeheartedly putting myself in
there
and how the [ __ ] do I really expect
something great to come out of that it's
not even it's really not even possible
because I'm trying to get if she's got
50% and I've only putting in 40 but I'm
expecting for the relationship to show a
hundred percent and then I'll still sit
there and [ __ ] be disappointed like
all this relationship any this ain't
shut this isn't it this isn't it of
course it isn't it
because I got that [ __ ]
you know I'm keeping one of my cards
over here by me because they nobody
getting all my cards
ain't nobody getting all my percents oh
man dude I fine
you know sometimes I just you know I
love I love uh I'm grateful I'm grateful
to be alive I feel good but sometimes I
wish on some of this emotional [ __ ] I
was just that was smoother brah
man I wish I was smoother I wish I just
didn't I have so many [ __ ] hang-ups
and I it's like dude take it easy take
it easy why and I am I'm taking it easy
brah
but if I don't try to work on myself and
do something better than I'll tell you
exactly where I here's where I end up I
end up yeah I end up with you know just
kind of serially probably dating get
into relationships here and there and
never probably having a healthy family
that's why I end up so and that's why I
[ __ ] care you know that's why I care
so anyway thank you so much for your
call man let's hear one more about the
commitment then we'll get into a couple
of uh do we have some ridiculous [ __ ] I
can't believe that dude said I you know
that Latino dude is like a [ __ ] you
know sometime you just got a [ __ ]
[ __ ] teller you [ __ ] love her bro
you know that was our dad's name rich
you know oh yo Co this two out of four
jigna that's and I was listening to your
podcast number 125 where you're talking
about commitment and I was in a a for 12
years and I've got a lot of value out of
it and you know I I think it's a
wonderful place and I do drink now but
it's working out for me okay but listen
you're on the right path you know you're
you're thinking the right thoughts and
you're an introspective guy you'll be
all right just don't you're you're
thinking about commitments and if you
can commit just just don't try to prove
to yourself that you can commit by
committing to the wrong girl you know
and I'm look and I'm learning by when
you're talking because I'm realizing
that one of the things I'm trying to
realize more of my life is just to
listen to others you know and because me
thinking I have the answers to
everything that's what [ __ ] you know
that's not true or I wouldn't be
struggling so the best thing I can do is
listen to others ask and not always take
their advice or take their suggestions
but listen to them just listen to it you
know and if I do see somebody who I know
has success in that in an area I want to
have success in then I can ask them and
I can take a suggestion from them you
know I'm out here struggling with
commitment struggling this so I'm gonna
talk to guys who have success in
committed relationships and talk to them
how they do it and I respect what you
said about don't force a relationship
you know don't force it you know it's
just it's so it's tough to know it's
tough to know it's tough to know it's
tough to know but it's tougher not to
try you know it's tougher not to try I
appreciate your thoughts and concerns
and suggestions you know I'm just trying
to take actions and keep my feet moving
and keep my brain still I want to let
you know about professional and
affordable counseling we all need it and
this is a site that I have tried this is
a service that I have used I've used
this service more than once and I enjoy
it it's better help.com you can go to
better help calm slash Theo today and
and you can get matched up with a
counselor that's right for you they're
professional and affordable counseling
and there are four communication modes
text chat audio audio chat
phone and video so you can start
communicating in under 24 hours you must
be 18 or over you can schedule sessions
you can send messages with your
therapist I was the last therapist I had
on there was a woman named Anna and you
know it's just sometimes you need help
and sometimes they don't have somebody
you know where you can get it and now
they do financial aid is available it's
easy to change counselors if you don't
like the one that you start with or that
that you get paired up with and let me
say that this in my experience to me it
has been imperative that when I didn't
like a counselor I didn't feel
comfortable that I made a change now I
didn't want to end up with someone who
just agreed with everything I said I
wanted somebody that challenged me I
wanted somebody that made me think most
importantly for me I wanted somebody
that made me feel like if I noticed in
therapy if I really started to have
emotions and feel something then that
meant that for me that that therapy was
truly working you can go to better help
calm slash Theo th EO today and uh and
see what they got for you if you need it
if you don't need it you know then
that's good and that's beautiful bra
let's take this hitter right here
homework potatoes Wyatt just left the
Bryan Callen of friends felt economy
store tonight and you were on the roster
but I didn't see you there bro similar
sad wondering why you're not there
thanks for calling Wyatt you know and
I'll talk about this real fast about
depression you know last week last week
I missed the here's the comedy show that
I missed okay
it was Bryan Callen Vernon child who I'm
wearing their t-shirt today firing the
kid two men that have been so good to me
Joe Rogan a man that has been very good
to me bill burr and Chris D'Elia two of
the funniest men around all those men so
funny
it and I missed that I missed that that
I was on the lineup and I missed it
because I wasn't feeling good man and I
just kind of threw in the towel for the
day and I just took a just went took a
nap you know I didn't take any pills I
don't do nothing like that but I just
said I you know I need to I need to take
a break and that's that's that's that's
something that happened you know that's
something that happened to me and the
worst part was later that night I had
other sets later that night that I went
I went too but I'm sorry that I wasn't
there and and you know I've gotten you
know the week went on and I got you know
I've picked myself kind of more up and
now I'm cruising you know here's what
I'm doing I'm focusing on focus on
moving my feet and I'm focusing on doing
the work you know contrary action I was
laying in bed I'm like [ __ ] I don't want
to go to yoga the class starts in 15
minutes so what did I do
I went to yoga you know in the next day
I don't want to go to yoga to class so
what did i do i went this morning I got
up man there's an a a meeting it's 20
minutes in 20 minutes it's nine minutes
away what do I do
I moved my feet move your feet your
brain will follow you if you are
struggling with that kind of stuff move
your feet your brain will follow you but
don't up but to me that [ __ ] is not a
game bruh that [ __ ] will take you out of
your desires if you de told me five
years ago you can be on a show with
Chris D'Elia varnish shelves Brian
Collins Joe Rogan's bill burrs
[ __ ] given I would have given both my
arms and both my legs to be on that show
you would have had to bring me on a
stage in a wheelbarrow but I got
depressed the other day and that's what
happened but I'm not but now I'm back
and I'm fighting back and that's why I'm
mad bruh so you want to see me out in
these emotions get out here boy
bang bang son you know what I'm saying
bruh I'll break open the asses of
somebody's of uh you know if dead miss
Wilson and let's [ __ ] throw it up
okay
I'll [ __ ] get yikes Wilson to turn on
that GNR and let's see who's who you
know what I'm saying we all go on to bed
with with uh with dead miss Wilson dust
on our soldiers bra you got to get that
Miss Wilson off your shoulder onward
let's take another call thank you for
calling my and I'm sorry that I wasn't
there and it won't happen again bruh
onward hey Co this is Tony
I'm calling from Wisconsin so I'm just
got a comment about your whole you know
the whole taking time away from you know
handling man handling yourself so okay
you talking about putting the brakes on
that uh you know you're talking about
putting the brakes on you know um you
know that mast he masty that that mast
eBay she homework I've been currently
doing the same thing and I've been going
strong for a good about nine months ooh
Tony got some time boy it'll tiempo
Antonio huh Tony got some time on word
so it's been nine months since I've been
like you know abusing myself so it took
me out I've been going that long so
congratulations man once a at nine
months man that's fascinating dude some
years only have nine months in Umbra a
long time ago the Mayan calendar nine
[ __ ] months so you win in Maya you in
a year bro back in Maya so
congratulations man Oh word my question
is I developed a new problem where you
know I think Satan's got me you know he
comes in the air at night time so I'm
dealing with the whole nocturnal
emissions mmm the whole you know wet
dreaming oh yeah man I
you brother [ __ ] dark bust homework
um so I just wanted to get your thoughts
and you know what you think about a
situation like that so appreciate
everything got for me
amen Tony I appreciate you calling and
you talking about the dark bust you know
you talking we used to call it um what
did they call it when I was young that
uh that Aladdin jizz cuz you would think
you know you wasn't gonna have it
because you haven't been rubbing your
lamp and then BAM your dick just starts
granting you [ __ ] wet wishes in the
middle of the night and they would call
that that Aladdin jizz but yeah I feel
you man look it's almost look that dark
bust is dangerous because you don't
think you know you you know you you
changing your game and I applaud you for
nine months nine to two not do anything
for nine months is fascinating brah and
it takes such it takes willpower and
that's way that it takes that manhood
you know and you did that man he did
that congrats on that but yeah bruh that
dude it's crazy you know in a long time
ago back in you know wizarding days and
people had witches and all that kind of
[ __ ] and you know people eating frogs
and all of that they um they would you
know they would um if you busted out in
the middle of the night they ain't
[ __ ] get rid of you you know or some
people thought you were a damn you know
you were probably you probably had a
leak you know he had that sub that sub
current you know that subconscious leak
but yeah maybe you got that [ __ ] wild
drip drip but I would say that this man
that you are blessed brother you know
you're blessed and I agree man look cuz
here's the thing about Satan baby boy or
s at Norse and satins gonna find a way
to get it out of you
because think about what it is it's in
you what what is inside of you is the
you know that body jism and that is
something you want to hold at your
manhood brother
that's your manhood that's your children
are in there that is your children that
is your great great great great grand
pop that's AB that's it that's it that
it is in your body it is in your jeezum
and if you and that's why I hadn't it
that's why you know the devil try to get
it out of you and whether he gets you to
play that you know that you know that
one you know that one shot monkey or
whether he gets you - um you know - he
lulls you into those dark dreams and
then he'll spray it out of you while
you're resting you know that dark bust
he's gonna try and get it out of you but
let me say this if he gets it out of you
through the nocturnal emissions that's
you didn't help him
you got no fingerprints on the weapon
brother you don't you know I'm saying
that's not your crime so if you want to
let Satan be a criminal that's fine
because he is a criminal and he's gonna
get that out of you you know he's gonna
get that and mmm-hmm that now they're
selves you know he's gonna you know he's
gonna pull that know their selves out of
your sauce router but don't you help him
and that's why I'm proud of your brother
I'm so proud of you man thank you for
calling and that was Tony right there
and he sounds like a brother out there
in Wisconsin and first of all Amen on
being her brother in Wisconsin I can't
even imagine you know it's I mean look
well probably these days man you know a
lot of ladies they lookin for that dark
spark my boys got it boy two-tone Tony
out there bro he got the full tank and
he's got a you know and he's got that
you know that Cuervos skin that Cafe de
kerlor I'm proud of you brother don't
jerk off man
stay safe brother Godspeed to you well
let's hear more let's hear another call
hey man this is Blake oh lake from Texas
hey Blake from Texas thank you for
calling Texas when I'm probably one of
my four favorite states probably let's
hear more
okay I'm Melissa I can and you tell
people to kill people killed not kill
people to kill deer with a knife
that's like unethical dog you can't have
people running around killing deer with
with with machetes running around that's
like that makes it super painful and I
think what it is I know what it is so
when you hunt you're shooting a deer
from high over many miles away and
you're shooting them to where they die
instantly where you ain't got to worry
about them hurting and squirting and
he's like if you get a heart a heart
shot there they're done but if you run
around chasing them with with a machete
playing hide-and-go-seek man we in play
now come on now come on man you're
making this sound like a playground
activity like this third grade recess
and they have children out there and
they have deers out there what I'm
trying to share with you my friend is
that if a if you get out there with an
IKE if you're good with a knife okay if
you out there [ __ ] you know Charlie
Chaplin on that deal you know if you
[ __ ] Ginsu Johnny out there didn't
you gonna kill him with one stroke
so you don't say you can't do it if you
could shoot something from you know 60
miles away with a rifle then you can get
up close and get that bad boy in that
gut gut you know pop him in them in that
in that red hitter you know get him up
in that [ __ ] play in that plasma tank
bro I'm just saying man be a man about
it I'm not saying this unmanly to hunt
I'm not saying it's unmanly to shoot him
like that with the guns but I'm saying
go double man-bra double manly you ever
been double manly go kill a deer with a
knife dude don't use a gun anymore
use a knife get out there and go
toe-to-toe with that month huh yeah let
him use his skills what have you been
doing something and even practicing
because a deer can't use a gun there but
their arms can't shoot a bullet that's
what I'm saying let's hear another call
thank you for calling man and look I'm
not saying it's unethical you know if
you kill you feed your family then
that's fine you know but I'm just saying
let's give these deers a real chance
let's film that [ __ ] and let's put it on
the internet bruh and let's see what God
let's see who God really wants to win Oh
weird uh let's take another call
what's up feel I love the podcast my
name is Brian I was just calling to I
guess hold myself accountable a little
bit I've struggled with addiction in the
past
I'm thanks for calling Brian I
appreciate you call him in let's hear
more recovering alcoholic so I know for
me telling other people that my
intentions helps keep me accountable and
key in lines oh that's interesting when
you're saying that telling other people
about your intentions it keeps you
accountable and keeps you in line you
know what's funny for me is I find that
if I don't tell people I'm doing
something I usually have better success
doing it like I
better if I don't tell people you know
because once I tell people let me think
about this so once I tell people it's
not my thing anymore
then it's our thing and I don't like
that you know or there's part of me that
you know some something inside of me
that's messed up doesn't like that it
likes things to be my thing so I would
rather because then it's just me it's me
against the world if it's just me but if
I tell you what my plan isn't what I'm
doing then it's like all now it's
everybody you know anybody can ask about
it other people and that makes it less
likely or that used to be my mindset
especially when I'm thinking like when
I'm young I wouldn't want to tell
anybody anything just do my [ __ ] you
know I would be like that you know that
Eminem styling [ __ ] telling these
[ __ ] you know these people out
here wearing these tank tops you know
eating you know eating gelatin and all
of that [ __ ] [ __ ] them bruh a bunch of
haters out here bruh but now I noticed
more I'm more likely to share something
as like oh because before I would want
to keep things as a secret you know it's
like oh I'll do what this guy was
surprised everybody everything had to
have this you know this big thing to it
but now it's like I can see like oh I
can think about something I can talk to
other people and get help with it and
then it's easier to come true because
it's not me doing it by myself but
that's difference between you know my
old my instead of thinking me against
the world and thinking a little more now
like me with the world but it still
flares up sometimes where I'll be afraid
to share something that I want to do I
won't want to tell people cuz when I do
tell people then I feel like I don't
want to do it anymore
because now everybody knows it's not
unique let's hear more thank you for
calling
onward so with that being said I'm about
to head out on a two-week trip in the
wilderness and my goal my intention is
to
oh you got that Hansel about to get all
Hansel out there boy
bring your bread comes breath you know
get a bag of them mom get a bag of them
crumbs daddy don't go out there with
nothing maybe take a gun or a knife or
you know and some and at least some
breadcrumbs so people can find you back
let's hear more or some yarn a lot of
time they do yarn till you could tie
yawn where you start and then keep going
till you know and then if you die or
something people can you know pull you
you know find you with the yarn homework
to not celebrate the Dark Arts then
beside in the time that I'm gone and mmm
that's gonna be a struggle for me to go
14 days without doing that so I wanted
to tell somebody and you're the you're
the guy I know that was for that so
hopefully I can accomplish that and keep
doing what you're doing and appreciate
it well I get man I'll keep you in my
prayers brother you know and I'll pray
you keep them full nuts on you you know
you keep as much [ __ ] magma in them
in them little [ __ ] you know spunk
holsters as much Magnum as you can and
much of that [ __ ] daddy magma and
I'll be praying for that man but yeah
two weeks in the woods dude who man cuz
nothing used to make me jerk off more
than seeing like a um like a shooting
star dude if I see a shooting star boy
you get 90% chance I'm gonna come
somewhere bruh that's just a 90% chance
but I wish you well man you know things
that would you know I remember you know
I used to live by some woods and a lot
of things and this is when I was a real
reactionary masturbator and a
reactionary masturbator is somebody who
masturbates you know in reaction to
something so some people they show up in
masturbate for no reason that was not me
I would something would happen and then
I would masturbate you know that's more
my style and you know things that would
do it for me shooting stars you know
birds chirp
Birds one bird chirping bruh I touch a
nut and son you only see him my work bro
three birds out there hitting a high
note dull skittle it eat it eat it eat
it eat
call me captain skeet skeet you know so
it's you know that what else would get
me those biker gangs if a bunch of
bikers went by and all the loud loud
laugh those [ __ ] people call them
[ __ ] yet those guys out of fear then
I would reaction airily have to jerk off
cuz then i would fall asleep after um
trying to think of anything else
definitely some other stuff like
different types of artwork and stuff
like that but those are the main things
but what else are we talking about here
but you're gonna be in the woods for two
weeks dude man that's gonna be hard I'll
pray for you but I think it's gonna be
hard because you're not getting anything
to do man and I'm saying you can only
start so many fires before you got a
jerk-off no I'm saying there's something
also about that fire seeing fire the
darkness I start thinking about Dances
with Wolves brah
back when Kevin Costner was young son
Shh come on somebody I'm about to bust
out but thank you for calling Manning
good luck out there let's hear another
call a lot of people call them on jerkin
off let's go homeward hey do don't have
a little problem you know I called it it
Tom everyone knows me is Connie so I'm
at this point in my life where I feel
like where I'm doing to be more adult
like I'm 21 right now I got a okay happy
21 brother you feel like you need to be
more adult like ohm word I got a
business and I'm turns out at the
chicken business and I just want ooh so
you trying to go from landscape to wings
huh
that's a unique jump daddy you're out
there boy you trying to go from [ __ ]
landscape in the wings boy from them
hedges to them [ __ ] way them sod
hitters Doug blue cheese blue cheese
working juicing with their adult life
you don't think I've always been worried
about when I would have to put my name
to Tom I'm just wondering if I have to
is that the appropriate and it's the
good news to the edge so you know I
didn't appreciate the part yet thank you
for calling Tom Tommy so he's asking
when do you change your name to Tom from
Tom me if he's Tommy now when he's you
go to Tom
that's a good question man when you go
to Tom you know I got a friend named
Timmy and he's bout maybe might be 61
you
point is while you know is wild you know
I got a buddy 50 buddy 50 and he he go
by Randy now he's hunting this
gentleman's homosexual he's homoerotic
for other men
but so it works kind of but still when
does it stop
you know what point like Johnny Manziel
Johnny Manziel doing dope in Cabo San
Lucas
but John Manziel is probably now you
know he'd be in his fifth year you know
maybe taking the Cleveland Browns to the
AFC playoffs you know so I definitely
agree at some point you got to change it
you got to let that you know you got to
let that alphabetical snake skin fall
off to the ground and you got to shed it
but that's a good question when do you
change you know from Billy to bill you
know from Waskom the Wasco I guess they
call it a Moscow you know from Jerry to
Jer you know from Donnie to Don you know
when you win do people also change from
Richard to dick
first of all go back to Richard bruh I'm
Nessa so wild to me but thanks for
calling you know we can put that out to
our listeners when do you change that
name what is inappropriate time or do
you when do you pick up a nickname
you know these step about this boy boss
call it they call him nut nut and he was
regular but he didn't really need that
name because he was never gonna work in
business you know and in a small town
working in business just mean working at
the bank but nut nut ain't getting a job
at the [ __ ] bank table you know
Stanley will work at the bank but nutnut
won't let's take another call man but
that'll be one for listeners you can hit
the hotline with suggestions for when do
you change that name nine eight five six
six four nine five zero three also you
know you can hit the hotline for any
thoughts questions comments struggles or
suggestions anything thank you guys so
much for your support let's take one
more call here our CEO
before your food bank gang gang gang
baby boy hey Supes boy the soos is loose
mas mas Mouse let's go iron Arizona mean
desert gone cuz I'd remember my old verb
em down there since I started listening
in about a year ago wow thank you so
much man thank you for listening bro
homeward and I don't know I didn't have
in the world turns I'm on my way into
work that job I [ __ ] hate a good job
that thing job pays his bills provides
for the family but I hate it kind of
from myself breaking hmm he hates it he
kind of feels himself breaking homework
yeah so my question to you is what's
your recommendation on yourself
equipment you know ready to get the hell
out of here
I Drive two hours one way some you work
12-hour shifts you know got a crew of
guys that ends on I [ __ ] hate it hate
my bosses you know not their fault they
got job they got a place they gotta run
but [ __ ] Aiden yeah let me know what
you think I will man I appreciate you
calling man you know I don't have any
advice for you you know I'll try and
offer some suggestions of mine you know
I you know I mean I noticed some things
about what you just said is that like
for one you're very aware you um and I
and thank you so much for calling in and
asking us for our suggestions you're
very aware bro you know you're aware
that you have a crew that works under
you you know in that you know that they
would be disappointed you said you're
aware that your bosses you don't like
them but you recognize they're just
doing their job like you know you're
you're very aware of your scenario I
don't think I would quit until you have
another plan you know you got to have
another plan the long commute
um man you know I wish you were happier
you know I wish that you were happier
and I don't mean that in a derogatory
way at all man you know I just wish that
you were happier about your situation
you know you do have a job you know and
that's great and you sound like you have
a family that you said you had a family
I'd go back and listen but I don't know
how to work this thing my producer set
up you know what you know what why don't
we ask the listeners man let's ask the
listeners this would be a good place
let's ask the listeners if you have you
know any suggestions you know a job that
he doesn't like he has to drive a long
commute two hours you said but four
12-hour shifts I mean I could see
somebody doing that you know you just
yeah I don't know man I haven't been in
that position but I'm sure there's some
listeners out there that have so those
are a couple things we can get
suggestions on if you have a suggestion
for one of those when do you change your
name from you know a baby name to a you
know to an adult name and then some
people like get a girl in my class when
I was growing up this girls Sampson was
the last time asthma was their first
name asthma Sampson and what I don't
even know if you ever change that
some names you don't ever change but uh
when do you change you from a little
boy's name to a man's name and you know
because sometimes you want to go from
[ __ ] cutting yards to [ __ ]
slanging Wang's bro and then secondarily
that job you hate what do you do you
know what do you do because we're all
there sometimes we're all there in
certain moments you know now I mean I
know I'm fortunate to be doing a job
doing stand-up comedy that I love but
there's times where I'm stuck doing
something for a day a week here and
there where it's tough and it's not
something I want to be doing but there
might be other listeners out there who
have had more experience with the
commute how do you change either change
your perspective or change your your
actual job but don't don't don't quit
your job in the meantime let's see what
some of our listeners might have hit the
hotline ninety five six six four nine
five
zero three you know I had a brief moment
the other night I was at the Comedy
Store and I just want to thank you guys
they had a you know a fella came up to
me he's in the Air Force and I don't
remember his name but he is from Buddy
were there and he came up and he said
man thanks for your podcast he goes the
other day on your podcast you were
talking about a software and it's called
covenant eyes and Co ven a NT e ye s and
he goes and it's like you know it's a
it's a blocker you can put on your
computer so you don't you can't look at
pornography and he goes that's what I
you know I used that now I never knew
about it before and and you could tell
that he you know he was just happy to
know about it and and so I just want to
remind people that that stuff is out
there but that made me feel good I was
having a [ __ ] OH
this past week was hell man it was
hectic you know but now I'm moving my
feet I'm moving my feet man I ain't
sitting around [ __ ] on my feelings bro
my feelings don't know what I want to do
my feet do my feet do what do I do next
that's what I do the next right action I
do the next right action what am i but I
just walked in the room what am I
supposed to do I don't take my shirt off
and throw it on the dinner table I go
put my shirt in the hamper okay then
what do I do
do I go outside you know you know I
smoke cigarettes no I go make a smoothie
in the kitchen because why because I
need to feed myself and take care of
myself and then what do I do
do I go just sit and watch Dateline for
the rest of the night no I take care of
some of the mail that's been backing up
you know and I get the house you know I
get the house in order and walk through
and get things tightened up you know I
take care of the next thing I need to do
that's what I do
I don't think and think and think about
I know what it is do what I'm supposed
to [ __ ] do and then before I know
what I got all my [ __ ] done then I can
relax and my brain will leave me alone
because I don't have a million things
looming to do then I'm free anyway I'm
not preaching that you man I'm just
you know I'm trying to get myself in
line bro sometime we got a line man I
wish I was a [ __ ] fat baby bro
don't you ever wish that I do all right
man thank you guys for all the love and
support we'll leave out again man with a
little bit of uh this another Jameson
flood song and this one is called every
night
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
they put on a show
you guys be good to yourselves man you
probably deserve it bro
you know you do we're trying to be good
to myself man and I put so much pressure
on myself you know and take a little bit
easier you know I've been putting a lot
of not pressure I just been I don't know
I'm not gonna think about it
he's gonna [ __ ] move my feet though
I'm gonna go piss and I'm gonna go home
I'm going to a birthday party tonight
for dr. drew I'm gonna go to that and
I'm just gonna listen other people and
have fun man and not try to [ __ ] do
too much that's what I'm gonna do
thank you guys for being a part of of
this episode man it means a lot and
onward amen
[Music]